[Música]
es un placer estar con ustedes Soy Paula
Jiménez Correa y les doy la bienvenida
Así es Asia el magazín quincenal de
France 24 que aborda las múltiples
realidades de este continente Estos son
nuestros titulares
China y Rusia fortalecen sus relaciones
así lo han dejado ver los presidentes y
Vladimir Putin durante su amistoso
encuentro en Moscú en el que ha quedado
Claro que sus lazos Más allá de
estratégicos son convenientes
Corea del Norte intensifica El
lanzamiento de misiles en lo que va a
ocurrido de este 2023 ha lanzado al
menos 20 entre ellos uno de alcance
intercontinental todo esto en respuesta
a los ejercicios militares realizados
entre Estados Unidos y Corea del Sur
en Japón fue creado el primer libro
manga con Inteligencia artificial
amenaza o avance para esta industria lo
veremos en esta edición
iniciamos nuestro recorrido por el
continente asiático con El encuentro
entre el presidente de China y su
homólogo de Rusia Vladimir Putin en
Moscú en el que ambos destacaron el buen
momento por el que pasan su relaciones
beijina ha señalado que el balance de
este viaje de amistad como lo ha
catalogado es muy positivo gracias a la
firma de diversos acuerdos en materia de
seguridad en la construcción del
gasoducto fuerza de Siberia 2 con el que
Moscú Espera que las importaciones
chinas se puedan multiplicar y otros
acuerdos de carácter económico pero el
tema central sin duda fue el plan de paz
propuesto por China para finalizar la
guerra en Ucrania al que Putin le dio su
visto bueno
como lo decíamos Los lazos económicos
entre China y Rusia se han fortalecido
en los últimos meses veamos en este
gráfico los principales intercambios
comerciales entre los dos países
Moscú provea Beijing principalmente de
energía gas natural petróleo metales y
granos todos productos clave para que el
gigante asiático mantenga su desarrollo
industrial Beijing el principal socio
comercial de Moscú por su parte le
provee equipos de tecnología
computadores productos mecánicos y
eléctricos automóviles y autopartes
además de la financiación de bancos
chinos a Moscú que ha aumentado desde
las sanciones impuestas por occidente a
Rusia por su invasión a Ucrania para
analizar los pormenores de estos
acuerdos económicos me acompaña Patricio
housto director del observatorio sino
argentino Patricio Gracias por aceptar
esta invitación y este encuentro ha
dejado Claro que se trata de una
relación de necesidad de conveniencia de
parte y parte especialmente en el actual
contexto de la Guerra de Ucrania y de lo
que esto ha acarreado un Vladimir Putin
aislado internacionalmente y un chillín
tratando de rebajar las tensiones que
aumentan con Estados Unidos y otros
países de occidente qué conclusiones le
deja a esta Cumbre Bueno lo que hemos
visto en esta reunión es una
reafirmación de una alianza estratégica
que ha tenido un impacto a raíz de la
invasión que ha provocado Rusia en
Ucrania pero que lejos de haberse dañado
se ha fortalecido en lo económico hay
una mutua necesidad entre ambos hay una
relación estratégica basada en intereses
económicos y geopolíticos regionales
Pero por supuesto ahora tenemos una
relación mucho más asimétrica que antes
con una Rusia más dependiente de China y
una china que también a partir de este
apoyo se le han generado algunos
problemas que quiere resolver Y creo que
el principal objetivo de sí es
justamente que la guerra termine
con la presentación de un plan de paz de
12 puntos para poner fin a la guerra en
Ucrania Qué tipo de mediación está
buscando China y en este caso en
concreto
bueno a ver muchas veces se olvida Cómo
ha sido la política exterior de China
desde la década del cuarenta la fecha
una política exterior pacifista una
china que no ha invadido no ha iniciado
guerras y que incluso ya consolidada
como una superpotencia siempre ha
agregado por la solución pacífica de las
controversias este también es un caso
que es especial por el vínculo repito
que tienen Rusia y China tan particular
Pero lo que sí está haciendo es algo
Bastante lógico china ya es la segunda o
primera economía mundial Según como
midamos el producto y otras cuestiones
como el desarrollo tecnológico Así que
Es lógico que china quiera tener un
protagonismo con esto y sobre todo
cuando este conflicto involucra a un
socio estratégico como es Rusia y que
tiene un gran impacto negativo en otras
cuestiones para china por ejemplo una
cuestión de las cadenas de suministro
global y su relación con occidente china
genuinamente entonces quiere resolver
este problema uno puede decir desde una
lectura sesgada para beneficiar a Putin
pero hay que mirar un poco más amplio
todo lo que implica esta guerra para
china no solamente lo que es para Rusia
no
el secretario de estado de Estados
Unidos Anthony blinken ha dicho que abro
comillas el mundo no debe dejarse
engañar por ningún movimiento táctico de
Rusia con el apoyo de China qué piensa
usted de las reacciones de Occidente
Bueno yo no diría occidente en general
porque sería Injusto digamos la reacción
de Estados Unidos y sus principales
aliados ha sido tan esperable como
lamentable en el sentido de que no hay
una bala china como mediador está claro
que china probablemente es el principal
stakeholder Global en este momento que
puede tener una incidencia en esto para
que haya una salida de negociada pero
los Estados Unidos no apoyan esto los
Estados Unidos tienen un objetivo que es
contrapuesto lo ha dicho la misma el
secretario de estado y otro funcionarios
queremos La derrota de Rusia Rusia debe
ser castigado Putin debe ser castigado y
Rusia debe ser derrotada en esta guerra
china va por una solución negociada cree
que es el mejor camino entonces mientras
esos objetivos no estén alineados
cualquier gestión que intente si no va a
tener el apoyo de Estados Unidos y sus
aliados principalmente estoy hablando de
g7 diotan Entonces es dable pensar que
gestiones de chino van a poder llegar un
buen Puerto hasta tanto y cuando eso no
cambia no Lamentablemente para los
ucranianos y para todo lo que están
involucrados en el desastre de esta
guerra no hemos visto en los últimos
años Los crecientes lazos entre China y
América Latina y el aumento de las
relaciones comerciales precisamente el
presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva viajará a Beijing Para reunirse
con qué podemos esperar de este
encuentro
lo que podemos esperar Es que la
relación entre Brasil y China crezca
Brasil es la principal economía de
latinoamérica principal socioeconómico
de china en Latinoamérica
complementariedad económica natural
impresionante
agricultura petróleo etcétera un montón
de Campos donde esta relación Ahora que
vino Lula con bolsonaro esto se enfríe
un poco nada está destinado a crecer y
Brasil va a darle un golpe fuerte creo
la diplomacia estadounidense en la
región porque va adherida la nueva ruta
de la seda Brasil es el principal país
de la región estaba pendientes adhesión
Y probablemente por la información que
tengo se va a concretar en esta gira de
Lula Así que va a ser otro país que
entra el más importante en este caso es
iniciativa algo que la diplomacia
estadounidense en la región ha venido
rechazando no
agradecemos a Patricio housto por su
análisis cambiamos de tema porque no
cesa la atención en la Península coreana
en lo que va de este año Corea del Norte
ha lanzado al menos 20 misiles
incluyendo uno intercontinental en
rechazo a los ejercicios militares
conjuntos entre Estados Unidos y Corea
del Sur veamos el informe de Andrés
triviño
la atención en la Península de Corea es
cada vez más fuerte Durante los últimos
días Estados Unidos y Corea del Sur han
realizado una serie de ejercicios
militares denominados escudo de libertad
los más grandes desarrollados por los
aliados desde 2017 las maniobras buscan
hacer contrapeso a la furia del líder
norcoreano Kim jong-un que hasta el 22
de marzo suma de lanzamiento de al menos
20 misiles balísticos en 10 ensayos en
lo que va del 2023 pero las alarmas se
encendieron aún más luego de registrarse
el lanzamiento del poderoso misil
intercontinental o asom 17 el cual
tendría la capacidad de llegar a Estados
Unidos este hecho se produjo unas horas
antes de que el presidente de Corea del
Sur jung-sum volará a Tokio para
reunirse con su homólogo japonés
fumicidad y discutir temas del armamento
nuclear de pyongyang y de conocerse que
el presidente estadounidense Joe biden
recibirá al sur coreano en la casa
blanca a finales de abril
ha respondido a lo que como
provocaciones de Estados Unidos con
amenazas bélicas asegurando que su país
debe estar preparado para lanzar un
contraataque nuclear recientemente se ha
visto acompañado por su hija Kim yuae
quien se cree tiene alrededor de 9 años
y podría eventualmente ser su sucesora
en el poder además el líder norcoreano
afirmó que alrededor de 800.000
ciudadanos se ofrecieron como
voluntarios para unirse al ejército
mientras que Estados Unidos y Corea del
Sur revelaron que sus ejércitos
realizarán en junio Las mayores
maniobras de fuegos real que han llevado
hasta la fecha para conmemorar el
aniversario número 70 de su Alianza
militar que se firmó tres meses después
de finalizar la guerra entre las coreas
en 1953 y que dio paso a una atención
militar continua
Pon el primer manga completamente
dibujado por Inteligencia artificial ya
está a la venta esto plantea preguntas
complicadas sobre una amplia gama de
temas desde los derechos de autor Hasta
La amenaza que la tecnología podría
representar para la industria masiva de
cómics en ese país
[Música]
es el último manga en llegar a las
tiendas y tiene a todos hablando pero no
es la historia convincente lo que está
causando revuelo más bien el hecho de
que ninguna de sus obras de arte fue
realizada sólo por manos humanas el
autor que se hace Llamar Ruth Ford usó
una herramienta de Inteligencia
artificial llamada Meet Journey para
renderizar todos los paisajes criaturas
y personajes el escritor de 37 años que
oculta su identidad con un avatar admite
que recurrió a la Inteligencia
artificial porque tenía absolutamente
cero talento para el dibujo
puedo decir que el dibujo con
Inteligencia artificial es mucho más
rápido que dibujar a mano mientras que
una ilustración a todo color le toma a
un artista un día completo no importa
qué tan rápido dibuje la persona esta
herramienta lo termina en
aproximadamente un minuto creo que esto
es una Clara ventaja
para crear su personaje principal Root
Ford introdujo frases como pelo Rosa
niño asiático y chaqueta Stadium para
evocar imágenes del héroe de la historia
en aproximadamente un minuto luego
presentó los mejores fotogramas en
formato de cómic asegura que tomó solo
seis semanas terminar el manga de más de
100 páginas lo que le habría llevado un
año a un artista hábil impresionante tal
vez pero ya ha habido una gran reacción
muchos en el mundo del manga están
planteando preguntas sobre la amenaza
que la tecnología podría representar
para los medios de subsistencia de los
artistas Y si la herramienta de
Inteligencia artificial podría estar
robando su trabajo
tendría mucho miedo de usar las
ilustraciones dibujadas por Inteligencia
artificial tal como están porque nunca
se sabe de quién es el dibujo que se
incluye allí las ilustraciones en bruto
de alguien Podrían haber sido recortadas
y reflejadas en las salidas de
Inteligencia artificial algunos artistas
de manga dan la bienvenida a la
Inteligencia artificial diciendo que
puede usarse como una herramienta pero
la mayoría sostiene que no hay sustituto
para los dibujos hechos por manos
humanas las empresas que proporcionan
las herramientas de Inteligencia
artificial también se enfrentan a
problemas legales una startup con sede
en Londres llamada stable difusión está
siendo demandada acusada de usar su
software para extraer grandes cantidades
de material protegido por derechos de
autor de internet sin permiso y para el
cierre les dejo este dato la bandera de
Filipinas tiene dos versiones una que
posee una franja Azul en la parte
superior y otra franja roja en la
inferior Esa es la bandera para tiempos
de paz sin embargo en un caso de
conflicto bélico la bandera invierte sus
colores quedando la franja superior en
rojo y la inferior en azul
llegamos al final de esta edición de Así
es Asia Muchas gracias por acompañarnos
y los invito a enviar sus comentarios a
la cuenta de Twitter que aparece en sus
pantallas y a seguir toda la información
en nuestra página web trans24.com y no
olviden nuestra cita quincenal
[Música]